excellent présent les états unis où les
plus hauts responsables militaires sont
auditionnés devant le sénat elle sont
entendus justement sur leur très
chaotique des troupes américaines
d'afghanistan
on retrouve notre correspondant à
washington thomas bonnet bonsoir thomass
retenir de ces auditions genre
eh bien ce sont des auditions très dense
qui se sont déroulées toute la matinée
et qui viennent de reprendre cet après
midi ici aux etats-unis avec une
deuxième salve de questions de la part
de ces sénateurs qui forment la
commission sénatoriale des affaires
militaires aux etats-unis leurs trois
personnes sont entendues il ya le
secrétaire américain à la défense lloyd
austin et autour de lui deux généraux le
général marc miley qui est le chef
d'état-major aux états unis et le
général kenneth mckenzie qui lui est le
patron du commandement central de
l'armée américaine alors ils ont d'abord
souligner le succès logistique de
l'opération à d'évacuation en
afghanistan mais ils ont aussi appelé à
tirer toutes les leçons et face à eux
donc beaucoup de critiques de la part de
ces sénateurs notamment des sénateurs
républicains et pour vous donner une
idée de l'atmosphère qui règne dans
cette salle d'audition l'un des
sénateurs lorsqu'il a pris la parole
pour les cinq minutes qui lui sont
accordées il avait avec lui une grande
pancarte sur laquelle il avait fait
agrandir la une du magazine the
economist et sur laquelle on pouvait
lire la débâcle de bail dun voilà qui
donne le ton de ces auditions donc
beaucoup critiquent ont été exprimées
par ces sénateurs notamment sur le
manque d'anticipation qui a mené à la
situation chaotique en afghanistan ou
encore sur le fait que treize soldats
américains ont été tués le 26 août
dernier dans un attentat à proximité de
l'aéroport de kaboul sur le fait aussi
qu'il y ait toujours des américains qui
sont en afghanistan et qui n'ont pas
encore pu être évacués ou enfin sur la
composition pour le moins polémique du
gouvernement par les talibans alors il
ya aussi la question de la crédibilité
des états unis aux yeux du monde après
ce qui est considéré par beaucoup de
personnes notamment au sein de cette
audition comme un véritable fiasco alors
pour vous donner un autre aperçu à des
échanges parfois un peu tendu qui ont
lieu lors de cette audition il faut
revenir sur deux versions qui s'opposent
puisque joe biden au mois d'août dernier
et avait affirmé qu'aucun conseiller
militaire ne lui avais conseillé
justement de laisser des troupes par
exemple de 1500 soldats américains en
afghanistan au delà de la date du 31
août et bien cette version a été quelque
peu contredite par les généraux lors de
cette audition ce que n'a pas manqué de
relever un sénateur républicain tom
cotonne en l'occurrence écouter cet
échange
dans une interview le mois dernier le
président obama a déclaré qu'aucun
responsable militaire ne lui a conseillé
de laisser un petit effectif en
afghanistan est ce vrai
les données ont été reçues et examinées
par le président c'est évident en ce qui
concerne ce qu'ils ont spécifiquement
recommandé comme je l'aï déjà dit ils ne
vont pas révéler ce qu'ils recommandent
confidentiellement au président
je trouve ça choquant cela veut dire que
potentiellement le meilleur conseil
militaire n'a jamais été présenté en
personne au président des états unis sur
un sujet si cruciale
vous avez entendu le secrétaire
américain à la défense lloyd austin qui
bottent en touche en quelque sorte mais
la polémique est en train d'enfler ici
aux etats unis puisque certains estiment
donc que des généraux ont pu être
ignorée dans la décision prise par le
président américain à l'été dernier au
point même que la porte parole de la
maison blanche qui donne son
traditionnel point presse à la
mi-journée a été interrogé ça a été la
première question qui lui a été posée
elle est revenue donc sur les
déclarations de joe biden du mois d'août
en faisant donc la comparaison avec
celle des généraux pour expliquer qu'il
n'y avait pas véritablement le sujet
mais je peux vous dire que la polémique
elle est bien réelle aux états unis et
puis un autre sujet aussi qui s'était
invité lors de ses auditions au sénat
puisque le général marc mulet le chef
d'état major des armées et au coeur lui
d'une autre polémique puisque dans un
livre qui s'appelle péril et qui est
paru il ya quelques semaines ici aux
etats-unis bien les auteurs affirment
que ce général ce chef d'état major qui
était déjà en poste à l'époque où donald
trump était président avait à l'automne
dernier échangés par téléphone avec son
homologue chinois pour le rassurer sur
le comportement donald trump en
affirmant par exemple qui le prêt
viendrait si le locataire de la maison
blanche décidé de la moindre attaque
contre pékin alors il est revenu sur ce
sujet il a devancé les questions parce
que vous l'imaginez beaucoup de
sénateurs l'attendait au tournant pour
l'interroger à ce sujet il a donc
devancé et toutes ces questions d'abord
en confirmant que ces échanges
téléphoniques avec son homologue chinois
avait bel et bien eu lieu et puis
surtout pour donner ses explications
écoutez le
je sais je suis certain que le président
trump n'avait pas l'intention d'attaquer
les chinois et c'est ma responsabilité
directe et c'était ma responsabilité
directe au nom du ministre de faire
connaître cette intention au chinois ma
mission à ce moment là était la
désescalade mon message était encore une
fois cohérent rester calme stable et
procéder à une désescalade
nous n'allons pas vous attaquez
à aucun moment je n'ai tenter de changer
ou d'influencer le processus
d'usurper l'autorité ou de m'insérer
dans la chaîne de commandement mais on
attend de moi on exige de moi que je
donne mon avis est que je veille à ce
que le président soit pleinement informé
sur les questions militaires
voilà donc pour cette journée marathon
d'audition pour donc le secrétaire
américain à la défense ainsi que ces
deux généraux ils seront entendus à
nouveau demain mais devant l'autre
chambres du congrès la chambre des
représentants il faut dire que les
américains ont véritablement nécessité
pour eux de comprendre c'est qu'il s'est
vraiment passé en afghanistan ce qui a
mené à ce fiasco et peut-être aussi et
bien retrouver les responsabilités là
l'illustration de l'importance qui est
accordée à ce dossier afghan et aux
conséquences qu'il peut avoir c'est que
ces auditions elles ont été retransmis
en direct toute la journée sur la quasi
totalité des chaînes d'information en
continue ici aux etats unis merci
beaucoup thomas bonnet en direct de
washington